Well,
how are you? Cristian Cásseres greets you with
his brief News Now report in
Spanish. The lawyers for former
Las Vegas Rangers player Henry Rights
appeared in court this morning.
Detectives say his blood alcohol level
was twice the limit and  that
was going 156 miles per hour when it ended up
crashing into another car on
rainbows near the junction with tropicana the other
vehicle caught fire and a woman
with her dog burned to death road
faces charges for driving under the
influence
resulting in death  and for
driving recklessly meanwhile
doctor jesús jara could keep his
job as superintendent of yes yes it is
tim the vice president of the board irene
cepeda asked for a new vote after the
decision to fire jara she voted
in favor for jara to leave
The president of the board of directors will retire from her post, she
said that they will discuss the
issue at a meeting on
November 18  bre members will vote
again to decide on the future
of heart
and the health district of southern nevada
continues to work to have
more doses of facer available for the last group
of eligibility we speak specifically
of the little ones from the age of
five and up they can be  vaccinate at any
valley health district office
yes days and walgreens are also
offering the vaccine and we close with
the weather forecast we will have sunny skies
with north valley winds
today we will be in the 70s we will hit the
80s again by saturday and
The temperatures will begin to drop
for next week I am Cristian Cásseres
with super informative information on innings in
Spanish, good day